Lucy I see
what have you been up to
no one's seen you for hours oh no to the
grindstone you know then why haven't I
heard a single whoosh through the door
since 10 o'clock did you forget we're
having dear Drew's birthday party we've
got a pinata right brilliant of course
have you forgotten your joy drug well
come on then finish up just have a few
more pages I know you're very busy then
don't take too long to finish aha
the Power Cells empty what will you do
I'll get a new one it can't be this hard
to finish up a day's work can it
there is fixed in the model with
practice both ways the cuff do you know
that you see the past is a garden Arthur
and you have to pull out the weeds to
grow anything nice how does she know
well I expect you in the conference room
presently don't dawdle we don't want to
miss the pinata oh those are prudent
supposed to be coming back today
I made our welcome back card
whatever happened to your prudence are
you I feel joy Pro I mean you two seem
to be a bit alike and I'll work now that
you mention it
we should fix them anteater bucket at
least there you are you nearly missed
the pinata
it's a most adorable Spanish custom
Uncle Jack did a whole show about it you
smash it all the candy comes out come on
hit it hit it
you are off your toy take one of mine
he's a downward cool security we got a
damn nerds for that's right
boys and tiny bed buckle how we mad or
is it the world
Oedipus didn't know he was doing but he
tore his eyes now it David didn't you
live down the line you just want them to
stop screaming that's all
I just want them to stop screaming
that's all
I'm late I'm late for any off the meet
hot we meet cold
London Bridge is falling down
toys and tiny watching the day go by
strange how everyone looks the same save
it for the next minute folks probably
starting to roll in a bell now
that's how are they old all honorable
men where do they live
you're not Airy you don't even look like
it strange hello everyone
this is not your business
you